economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela el
agua comenzó a cotizar en bolsa- por
temor a la escasez cuéntenos santiago
muy buenas noches lo hará en el mercado
de materias primas de la bolsa de nueva
york- como lo hacen también el petróleo
el oro o el trigo entre otros
commodities inicialmente se comenzó a
transar un índice con los precios del
agua de california que se han duplicado
en el último año por la escasez pero se
espera que después sea usado como
referente mundial china y eeuu son los
principales consumidores de agua y según
naciones unidas en los próximos años dos
tercios del planeta podrían experimentar
escasez pero que son los contratos a
futuro de santiago expliquémoslo un
agente financiero firma un contrato en
el que pacta comprar determinada
cantidad de agua a cierto precio y en
determinada fecha esto puede servir para
dos cosas o bien para asegurar el precio
y no exponerse a la volatilidad o
también para especular porque esa gente
puede jugar adivinar el valor en el
futuro y vender ese contrato
santiago cuando el agua se entrega
físicamente los contratos probablemente
ya han pasado por muchas manos porque
este es un mecanismo meramente
financiero y más que el propio líquido
lo que se está negociando son los
contratos pues ya veremos cómo se
desarrolla esta cotización en bolsa
daniela hay mucha expectativa también
porque los líderes del reino unido y de
la unión europea tienen una nueva mesa
de dialogo que comienza este miércoles
para ver si por fin logran un acuerdo si
santiago ya a londres tuvo un gesto
bastante amistoso cuando se separó de la
unión europea ambos ya habían aclarado
cómo iban a implementar las normas
fronterizas entre irlanda que es miembro
del bloque e irlanda del norte que hace
parte del reino unido- pero después
boris johnson promovió en el parlamento
la denominada ley de mercado interno que
se prestaba para dejar de cumplir esos
acuerdos
ahora decidió retirar esas polémicas
cláusulas con este punto resuelto hay
otra traba grande por solucionar que es
la pesca pues matías ahora de eso nos va
a explicar
ya que la amenaza de un break sí si me
acuerdo se avecina estos pescadores
franceses pronto podrían encontrarse
aislados de los peces británicos pasamos
todos los veranos en aguas británicas el
80% de nuestra pesca de verano proviene
de ella aquí en verano no hay nada si
para el primero de enero no hay un
acuerdo de break sheet tendrán que
pescar en aguas francesas
vamos a compartir esa franja de mar del
sur con todos los europeos los
holandeses y belgas será una catástrofe
la pesca se ha convertido en un amargo
punto de inflexión política a pesar de
representar una pequeña fracción de la
economía británica la última propuesta
de la unión europea para calmar a
westminster es dar al reino unido el 18
por ciento de toda la captura de los
pescadores europeos pero eso ha sido
rechazado por gran bretaña sin embargo
también hay mucho en juego para reino
unido ya que el 80 por ciento de su
captura se exporta gran parte de ella a
la unión europea en caso de no llegar a
un acuerdo estas exportaciones estaría
sujetas a aranceles
y quién se lo imaginaría daniela el
producto interno bruto de la unión
europea creció a un ritmo récord en este
tercer trimestre del 2020 santiago nos
quedamos en europa porque mire los 27
países del bloque comunitario tuvieron
un crecimiento conjunto del 11,5 por
ciento en el tercer trimestre de 2020 y
este ritmo se explica porque la
comparación se hace frente al segundo
trimestre que había sido bastante
afectado pues este es el más alto y
desde que iniciaron los registros en
1995 y revierte el resultado del segundo
trimestre cuando hubo una contracción
del 11 3% francia españa e italia que
habían sido los más golpeados ahora son
los que más crecen impulsados por un
mayor consumo en los hogares hablemos
ahora de los indicadores como las ffaa
las principales bolsas bueno pues el
wall street de cerró en positivo ya con
la vacuna hecha realidad la esperanza
creció también en los mercados en europa
por el contrario las pérdidas
predominaron por el bloqueo sobre el
break sit de nuevo con excepción de
londres y en américa latina hubo
resultados dispares santico
y para el cierre la siembra del día 4 16
billones de dólares millones de millones
recibieron los estadounidenses en
préstamos bancarios en octubre la
reserva federal destacó que sus
préstamos son para automóviles y para
estudio mientras que bajo el gasto en
tarjeta de crédito muchos números
daniela muchas gracias por esta
información es todo por el momento aquí
en la economía en france24 siga con
nuestra programación buenas noches
[Música]